Hello everybody!
Welcome back!
Oh wow!
Wait, long time no see!
Long time no see!
Did you get taller?
I don't remember the last time I was here.
There's nothing happening in this place before.
The place before.
Thank you guys so much for sticking around and welcoming
people that didn't catch part one.
Thank you!
It's...
Cookie Run Kingdom 2 Electric Boogaloo Time!
Electric Boogaloo Time!
Yeah.
But...
We were chatting a little bit before starting up stream.
After this, do you guys...
Did you guys know that Phoebe will be playing Winnie the
Pooh's home run derby?
Like, the masochist that she is?
Like...
Ah!
Calling me!
like this I look it's I've been trying to beat Winnie the
Pooh's home run derby like I would play it for almost every
anniversary since I started streaming and I was never able
to make it all the way to the end but today I'm going to try
again um the problem though and I was telling you meant this
is that it saves your data on the browser right like it's a
browser game so save there and last time people oh no sorry
go ahead oh yeah last time people watched me play was back
in november it was like right after we had done the densetsu
debuts and i had a different computer at the time so yeah
you switched recently and now i have a new you see yeah i
switched recently and i realized that all of my Winnie the
Pooh's home run derby data is gone.
So yay.
I was dying.
Yeah.
I was speed running trying to get back to the level that I
was at before.
There's like eight levels.
Some of you have watched Minto play it before.
But there's like eight levels and I had made it through six
of them last time.
I beat Owl.
And then I made it to Tigger, I think.
And then I couldn't beat Tigger, so I stopped there.
But today, today I like one, like I one tried everything
except for Owl, and I'm still stuck on Owl.
So we're a little behind, but we want to go.
Suffering continues, but, but after I beat it, I'll be free
from the curse.
Finally.
After all these years.
And all you have, you have just, you just have Owl, Tigger,
and Christopher Robin.
You got this.
Yes, just them.
Just them.
I got this.
Thanks for believing in me, Mimic.
Of course.
Someone does.
Honestly.
Thank you.
Like, for those who don't know that game, it's truly the
rage game of all time.
Like, I don't know how it's a kids game.
children actually played this and beat it that's like kind
of crazy to think about i think a lot of game like older
games were purposefully difficult like just to just to be
like see look you can't just beat our game and in two hours
you have to spend time and effort and you have to you have
to really understand the train in the mountains under
waterfall yeah dedicate your life to studying the blade, the
Winnie the Pooh's home run blade.
The bat.
Yes.
I studied the bat.
Weeks of fun.
Yeah, it definitely kind of artificially inflated the time
of how long a game would be to beat.
But this one, Winnie the Pooh's home run derby is like an
online flash game.
so why did they have to make it on the disney website why
and it has persisted because of it i know who hurt them a
baseball definitely apparently baseball yeah yeah baseball
goodness gracious see i believe in you for sure thank you
thank you I just want to be a gamer like you, Minto.
Like me?
Wait, wait.
Like you.
How am I a gamer?
Because you made it all the way to Christopher Robin.
I haven't yet.
But I didn't beat him.
Maybe I should also do a, like, a rematch against
Christopher Robin.
What do you guys think?
I believe in Minto.
I don't know if I believe in myself, but I believe in you.
But, you'll be able to, like, kind of work up to him a
little bit.
I feel like I won't.
Like, I will forget everything, and then it will be so
difficult.
It's okay.
It's...
We're playing Winnie the Pooh's home run derby is, like,
riding a bike.
It comes back to you.
It could have been years, and then it comes back to you
because it's been engraved into your neurons.
So true.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, some people are saying we could race once you catch
up.
today but like well unless i beat him today but i i don't
know if i have that confidence would you want to though if
you have to beat owl i could yeah you know what because i i
am streaming a lot later than i normally do so what i could
do is i could beat owl hopefully beat tigger no stop at
christopher robin yeah then we could race yeah i'm down i
have to see i'll have to see if i'm back it otherwise i will
have to replay the whole thing and i training it's your
training yeah my training all right well that's the thing
because christopher robin is like all of the moves combined
so that's terrifying yeah i didn't even know that because i
haven't gotten that far it's so scary
i there was a there was somebody else that i watched like it
was two Hollow Live members that did like a racing.
It was, I think it was ASCII and Korone?
And they did like a racing of like uh it was some other rage
game.
Um, what game was it?
Oh my gosh.
Uh, I think it was- I wouldn't be surprised if it was
betting over it or something.
It's something very similar.
It was something very, very similar.
And so they raced and it was, it seemed pretty fun.
So, it wasn't getting We could do that.
Prize.
Okay.
I'm excited.
I'm not.
Don't get that far.
Don't get excited yet.
Don't get excited.
You're going to play the game.
You're going to play the game tonight and then be like, you
know what, Min?
I don't think we can.
I don't think we should do this.
Yeah, we'll see.
We'll see how I feel.
We'll see if I am too a little bit.
too traumatized.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, it was a Sisyphus.
Yeah, yeah, it was Sisyphus.
I can.
Oh, Sisyphus.
Have you played that one?
Oh, that is a rage game that I haven't played yet.
No, I played Only Up.
I played Getting Over It.
Have you played Sisyphus?
Yeah, I almost beat it.
Oh, almost?
Almost.
I believe in you.
You could do it.
No, I don't- If you ever got back to it.
But that's a question of if you want to.
too?
I think I'm good.
Love yourself.
Love yourself a little more.
Yeah, like mint here.
Mint is, like, this is a good example of self-respect and
dignity.
Yeah, I was like, before stream, I was like, man, maybe I
don't feel satisfied by not beating Christopher Robin.
And then I was like, you know what?
No, I think I...
I think I'm okay.
You're good?
Yeah.
Maybe you're okay.
What's the worst kinds of games are like Are like rage games
like that That don't have like a Like you beat the game and
it's just like Like just a screen that says congrats You
beat the game like just that you know That's it So you would
expect something a little bit Just a little bit more Just a
little bit After all of that heartache Have you ever seen
like the ending that is That is from Getting over it?
like you solemnly swear you are not streaming
no no so then people like turn off their streams at that
point yeah yeah i've never i've still never seen it yeah
that's so interesting oh i know i wonder why it's a secret
it makes me want to see it but i'm like i don't want to put
in the effort and then also if i'm If I beat it, I'm going
to get carpal tunnel.
If I beat it, then also...
I have nobody else would be able to watch it on my stream.
Cool.
That's so sad.
You went through this whole journey together, and then you
can't go to the end together.
Yeah!
We should ask Nimi.
Oh.
We should ask Nimi what it is.
Nimi's beat it.
Yeah, Nimi's speed on it.
When Nimi was playing it, Her name is...
Oh my god, I remember.
We should!
We should just be like, Nimei!
What's the ending?
Tell us, please?
We have like big sparkling eyes.
We're like, please, please, please, tell us, tell us the
ending.
Please, please, Nimei, please!
And she'll be like, Oh yes, kid.
I can imagine, I should be like, yes, kid.
Mmm.
Yeah, she'll...
I don't know, you guys.
You should play with us.
the game that was good oh i don't know maybe you should
maybe you should just play and get your stuff yeah she'll
say she'll tell us that it's only worthy for for people that
beat it
i mean what if it really is that life-changing what if it's
that like that satisfying of an ending.
I feel like Only Up is the kind of game that would have an
unsatisfying ending.
You'll go all the way up there and then it would be like,
congrats, and then they would have like a time on it and it
would show you the ridiculous amount of time that you've
just been trying to get up.
Nah.
I don't know.
I've never beat, I've never, I think actually most rage
games I've never beat before.
Like Jump King and Only Up.
Actually, I've never tried Only Up.
Most of them I don't think I've ever been.
Yeah, now that I think about it.
How's Jump King?
I've heard about it, but I actually haven't seen any
gameplay of it myself because I was gonna like try to play
it myself.
I would say, I would say of all the, of all the rage games,
it's like the most relaxing.
Really?
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Like, because it's just, I don't know what it is.
I will keep that in mind, then.
This, it might be, it might be a controversial opinion, but
it's just, it's, you know, it's just like a, I don't know.
There's just something very calming about, like, the
ambiance in it, and, yeah, people are saying it's, like, a
quality rage game.
It's calming rage.
Yeah, it's just something about it.
That's like, yeah, I don't know.
Calming rage.
Maybe that's it.
Maybe that's my rage.
game that I need to play.
Phoebe's perhaps.
Well, there's another one.
Did you play did you play Emomushi when that came out?
Emomushi?
I don't think so.
No, wait.
No, I didn't.
I didn't.
That one was like a little bug.
Yeah, yeah, I haven't.
I haven't.
Oh, that one was a very Phoebe core raid game.
It is very... I'm looking at it right now.
I want to get back to it sometime It was very silly Very
cute But also I was not very good at it But I think It at
least was cute It does look very cute It was little bug
Little bug Little bug Little bug Yeah the BGM and Imobushi
is good Oh yeah That's always fun It's not like stuff that
like makes you go insane listening to it over and over and
over again.
No, not the freaking, not like the freaking Winnie the
Pooh's home run derby BGM, which everyone is going to have
burned into their minds by the end of tonight.
Yes, we will rate it to Phoebe after we go into some more
some more Cookie Red Kingdom.
Sorry, so sorry, everybody, for the issues before.
Thank you for sticking around because it's really it's i'm
excited to finally for us to be able to show everybody earth
bread and the kingdom and cookie run kingdom very cute very
fun and very super serious very serious at the same time
very serious oh my gosh the intent thing the account that
was given to me it's a temporary account so you know i don't
get to i don't get to keep it guys everything for the fifth
anniversary but um but the the kingdom is like stacked it's
it's so beautiful stacked out is nice yeah it's so so nice
welcome to our temporary crib is it like is it having a
temporary game account for a sponsored stream like having an
airbnb i was just about to say that renting out a nice
airbnb we're renting out the airbnb this thing so that
viewers think that we're like more like well off than we are
like yeah this is my kingdom it's real nice it's max level I
got everything a lot oh yeah oh yeah yeah come set foot in
my earth bread it ain't like your earth bread no it's not
like your moldy earth bread yeah I bet you don't even have
this max castle and max everything yeah Yeah.
Check out my hours.
My production lines are optimized.
Oh, yeah.
I got all my dailies.
Boom, boom, bam.
I got this.
Oh, yeah.
Every single cookie unlocked.
Well, there's quite a few people with every single cookie
unlocked, actually.
Well, you were saying that you joined an older server,
right?
And so that you, like, when you first started, so there were
already some, like, super powerful people in your server
that you joined.
Right.
It started January 2021, and I joined pretty early, but I
think it was like mid-year 2021.
So there's some people that have, like, a few months on me.
And then because I took a little bit of a break, I don't
have some of the newer cookies unlocked, personally.
And those are all the ones, like...
Are they the meta?
I was talking to my housemate about the meta, and she was
like, yeah, they're the meta.
She was like, here, let me help you build your PvP team.
And then I look, and I have, like, one of the cookies in the
meta.
No!
But if everybody uses that, I gotta catch up.
But game is super generous.
Yeah, you were saying that.
Let's see if it's back up.
Yeah, game is very generous, so I think we'll be able to...
Oh yeah, I think so.
I think it just came back up.
Let's see.
I will refresh my game as well.
I've had mine open too.
Let me turn off my music here.
I think it's ending in...
It says in 10 minutes for me.
Okay.
They said around this time for me.
So we can do another 10 minutes or so.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, close.
Goodbye, Q.
Yeah.
All good.
All good, all good, all good.
All good, all good.
all good.
Yeah, there's these codes over here that Minto put on the
screen.
Yes.
And whether you're starting new or you're coming back to the
game like me or you're just in the middle of playing it,
don't forget to enter your codes.
Enter your code.
There's a website for it.
I'll drop the link down below again.
Yes.
I mean, I think there's a way to do it in the app too, but I
just like use Um, they have like a website for it as well.
So I use it and then I just plop all the codes in and it's
real fast, real easy.
And they're giving away so much because it's the five year
anniversary.
Exciting.
That's half a decade.
I can't believe it's been that long.
Oh my gosh.
My account is like old enough to go to kindergarten now.
Isn't that crazy?
What were you doing five years ago?
Gosh, we were in pandemic.
huh so this was like my life cookie run kingdom was was my
everything and then i got my mom into it and she was
actually our guild leader for a while wait that's so sweet
right she was so good with it too pickman bloom is also a
family endeavor for my family too i remember you telling me
this yeah it was it was my guild i got busy with work so i
gave my mom was like let me take over it so then she became
the guild like the guild leader and she was like reminding
everybody putting little messages remember to do your your
dailies remember to do the guild bosses oh my god these are
the new these are the good teams that's so sweet i think we
lost our guild because uh uh ownership ends up going to the
to like for someone who's like most active Oh yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Oh.
That's usually how...
But maybe I'll get back into it.
Zen Setsu Guild.
I've never, I've never, yeah.
Oh.
So, I mean, we could try.
We could be the most powerful.
We could, maybe.
Take over.
We could be the most powerful.
They've reworked the whole guild battle system in recent,
recent, over the past like year or something too.
So, yeah.
There's so much more to do.
Exciting.
be learning new stuff too can i keep this account you know
right i looked at it and i was like oh i don't know that's
some delicious making a delicious looking kingdom right
there oh my gosh you guys i can't wait to show you it's
actually so and what i love being able to do in games is
picking up characters as they're walking around and you can
do that you can pick up the little cookies and be like
yeah we're keeping the air and some of them some of them are
like We'll keep, yeah, keeping the Airbnb.
We'll just, we'll just go to the person running the Airbnb
and be like, Hey, can I buy this off of you?
Yeah.
You.
Can I bribe you with some cookies, please?
They're very delicious cookies.
Made with Phoebe's very famous recipe.
Yes.
Definitely no secret ingredients or additives in it.
Nothing suspicious whatsoever.
Wait, what do you add?
Love.
I knew you were gonna say that.
Come on, Phoebe, we gotta get deeper.
We come home, ho, Phoebe, we gotta cook.
We gotta cook, Phoebe, we gotta cook.
Phoebe, we gotta cook.
We gotta bake.
Sorry,
I'm still on my breaking bad high.
Okay, Mr. White.
Okay, Miss Fantome.
Time to cook cookies.
Yeah.
They call her Mint White Fantome.
Mint her White.
Yeah.
That's so cursed.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, Mentor White.
Yes, good, good.
I'm going to have my ending.
Instead of, like, what was it, Bluebird or whatever, I'm
going to have, like, strawberry jam.
I just...
Strawberry jam.
Yeah.
I love your summary of Breaking Bad, by the way.
Wait, have you watched the show?
I've seen some...
I didn't get very far though.
I'm...
I wonder if there's a happy ending to it.
It was stressing me out.
I mean, it's good.
It's really well written.
It's good.
It's popular for a reason, but...
It is a good ending.
Okay, okay, good, good.
I'm just...
I was like...
peak stress when I was watching it.
I was just like, oh god, oh god.
Oh, that's so... that's so...
That's so sussy.
I know, it really is.
Yeah, it is a happy ending.
He's just trying to pay his bills, man.
He's trying to...
Yeah!
Relatable struggles to anybody in this day and age.
Anybody can relate to Breaking Bad.
We do not condone the actions of Walter Wise.
Everybody?
In this sponsored stream.
We do not.
Yeah.
We're talking about cookies, everybody.
Cookies, cookies.
Cookies.
We're cooking cookies.
We're baking.
Yeah, we're baking.
We're cooking.
Yeah.
Well, why is it called...
Why are they called cookies when you bake them?
Bakeies.
Why in of the oven?
When there was a bacon, you call bacon when you cook it.
Oh.
Oh yeah, oh my gosh.
And then cookies when you bake them.
What was the of in the oven again?
Yeah, of when you in of the...
Why do they call it of in?
Why do they call it oven?
When you...
Oven the cold food.
Of out hot eat the food.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I still don't understand.
I don't understand after all this time.
Why do they call it oven when you oven in the cold food of
out hot eat the food?
Because it's the oven.
What's the hot eat the food?
That's the out in.
That's the out.
That's the food.
That's the cold food of in.
The of in is the cold food.
Of out is the hot food.
Well, why is it hot eat the food?
Because it's hot.
It's got to go into the of in to become hot.
And then of out eat the food hot.
You're right.
So he's saying that...
That it should be called an...
It should be called an of out.
Yeah.
Well, you oven.
You oven.
The cold.
And of out.
The of out part is when you, it's hot and you eat the food.
Yeah.
I think I smell toast.
Are you hungry?
It's not a toasting stream.
It's a baking stream.
You should smell cookies, not toast?
Yeah.
Toaster.
Toast.
What?
You can put other things in the toaster.
Yeah, have you guys tried putting things besides toast in a
toaster?
I mean, besides, like, toaster strudels or pop tarts or
something?
Because those are supposed to go in the toaster.
Wait, they are?
Things that are not supposed to go in the toaster.
I've put in a bagel.
Who's going to the toaster?
I do.
No, not like a fork.
Don't do that.
Why am I seeing...
Don't put a fork.
No, not a fork!
Why am I seeing hot dogs multiple times?
How are you gonna...
Why a hot dog?
What do you put?
What if you put in...
Okay, what about a pizza slice though?
I saw a...
Oh!
Pizza slice, that's for now, yeah.
That could do it, maybe.
Sometimes microwaving it doesn't cut it, so maybe toasting
it.
Do we...
Do you put the hot dogs in sideways or vertically?
Uh...
I feel like if you wanted it to grow...
If you wanted it to cook all the way through, putting it in
sideways.
Sideway.
Vertical.
And then...
Right, because if it was vertical, the top would just be
sticking out.
Yeah, but probably.
If you put it in vertically, you could put like five of
those babies in there.
You're right, and then you just flip them over and do it
again on the other side.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, big ring!
You could do it!
Because if you put it in sideways, how would you get it out?
How would you get it out?
Why?
The maintenance!
It's over!
An update is available.
Wait, an update?
Wait, hold on.
I'm opening the game.
Did you guys forget that this was a sponsored stream?
What I'm gonna do...
I think...
Let's see if I need to update.
If I need to...
Update is available!
Oh, I do need to update it.
Let me see.
So what I had to do was I had to close it out fully.
Okay, okay.
And then there's going to be an update button next to play
game.
Okay.
Yes.
Where is...
How exciting!
We get to try out the new update right away!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
Exclusive update game.
Okay, it's updating.
Exclusive, wow.
Yeah.
Diddley, oh, updating.
Opening my game too.
Me too.
Diddley, diddley, diddley.
Oop.
Oop, updating still.
Exclusive world premiere.
Wow!
At the very second of the update.
New character idea, toaster cookie.
All right, let's play the game.
Little little little.
What I'm going to do is move us down here once again.
Oh, there is no toast cookie, but there's a French toast
cookie in oven break.
Yeah!
Download the pack.
And I just finished downloading.
I think we get another video.
So, that's why.
Ooh, exciting.
Yeah.
Well, okay.
Let me just...
Yeah.
Oh, oh, let me share my game with you.
Please, are you sorry?
Oh!
There's so much happening.
Thank you.
Yippee!
It's time for the Dark Enchantress War.
What?
Oh!
Let's go in.
What the?
There we go.
I like the little dragon guy with his cake.
His little cake guy.
He's so cute.
So, oh, first of all, we're going to show off.
We got, look at all these things.
We got this bear jelly sweet rush.
This is new for the, uh...
You know what?
Let's just go now, you know?
Let's just...
Yeah, let's just go look at it now.
Yeah.
We can do this.
Whoa.
The music is so cute.
A new mini-game!
Oh, yeah!
It's so cute.
New mini-game.
many mini games as well yeah i noticed that i don't know
what this is like new should we try it should we try it oh
here are the rules we'll start with easy first serve all
desserts to unlock the next difficulty level it's best to
clear difficulty level suited for you you can serve
unlimited desserts on challenge difficulties yes your skills
there don't forget if you reach your dessert match coin
limit for this season it will change to daily limit okay so
you have like a amount that you can win Let's get started.
Okay, let's try it.
Tell you how to serve desserts.
If different desserts are mixed on a tray, they can be
served.
So this is just a mini-game, you guys, like within the game.
Make sure to get...
They have so many mini-games, too.
Desserts disappear once you place three of them on a tray.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
If you want to move the dessert, top it on, and then top the
empty tray to move it.
You can move them by dragging.
Choose what's best for you.
in order desserts.
Get extra time for completing orders within the time limit.
The time limit will be reduced if you're late, so always
check.
We're nearly there if you're stuck while playing, try the
shuffle button.
Okay.
Be strategic with this button.
Use it only when you really need to.
Match, no, complete required number of matches within the
time limit to get all the dessert match coins.
Oh, okay, okay.
Alright, so we're trying to get things.
It's a gummy bear, you guys.
Wait, so which one's the... Oh, this is the...
Wait.
Which one's the try?
This is the plate, right?
So it's like, okay, hold on.
Or...
Yeah.
Oh!
Wait, okay.
So...
Oh, there you go.
Okay, you serve it on the brown one.
So, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then it'll kind of like tell you, okay, okay, okay.
Wait, this is...
This is...
This is easy.
Easy mode.
Like this.
Yeah, easy mode.
Yeah.
Oh, she wants...
Oh, wait, this is just like one of those like...
Own games I've played.
I know, I was literally...
just thinking that and she wants the chocolate so we got
that nice easy easy easy oh yeah we're naturals oh my gosh
she's so good serve queen serve yeah i'm serving oh yeah
you're serving oh yeah oh yeah oh shoot they look yummy
either oh i want cake oh yeah look at this one nice nice
there we go Uh, oh.
Does it show what...
Okay, uh...
Whoa.
Wait, I have nothing.
Oh, then...
And then if you do the matches on those rightmost trays,
then...
Okay, I see.
Oh, wait.
Oh!
Or if I think...
Oh, there you go.
You just have to move them over.
Yeah, and then you get the plate.
It frees it up.
Oh, okay.
Ah, sham, ah, sham, ah, sham.
So, like, if I do this...
Yeah!
Okay, okay.
Yeah, there you go.
and then we need to do oh huh this one and then this one
yeah yeah yeah no
easy easy that really is like one of those like phone games
those are so addicting though i know they really are they're
kind of like perfect just like like if i'm on a plane or
something turn your brain off yeah and also you have the
brain to be gone yeah i've got a plane yeah especially if
you have like no internet or something yeah yeah yeah but
guys let me introduce you to our kingdom that kingdom look
at this beautiful beautiful look there's so much everything
is so neatly built oh my gosh this area is so stinking cute
Which I love it.
They've sectioned it off into different areas according to
different, like, packs they've released in different parts
of the story.
So cute.
And you can see everybody's walking around.
And you can pick them up.
You pick them up.
They're so cute.
And then they, like, talk sometimes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They interact with the environment and with each other.
it's so stacked I think these different areas are based on
the beast cookies I'm pretty sure beast cookies like eternal
sugar cookie silent salt cookie crazy yeah there's so much
there's so much happening just for the fifth anniversary so
we showed like the the the jelly bear but there's also
there's like more shop there's stuff for the shops where you
can like spend your great apple coins you can collect and
you get uh you can get balloons and festival things so um
there's also there's just like there's so many events
happening for the fifth anniversary so even if you're a new
player like there's just so much to to check out and enjoy
there's a lot to check out yeah so much oh my gosh so much
actually let's see there's like a wheel of fortune and this
like lucky dice thing Anniversary gotcha as well.
Yeah, we have the anniversary gotcha.
We have the dark enchantress cookie, which we will pull for
her.
And of course, mold dough cookie.
We will pull for them as well.
And the costumes and everything.
And yeah, it's like...
Oh my gosh, it's so stinking cute.
What the heck?
Really stinking cute.
I feel like I could find myself getting addicted to the
jelly bear.
Or the bear jelly, sorry.
And then they talk like that too.
They're like, hello.
Hello.
You might want to...
Look at this.
Should we check out?
What do you want to check out first, Phoebe?
Oh my gosh.
I don't know, because there's like new story stuff.
And then there's the gotcha and the outfits and all of that.
Let's save the gotcha for last, I think.
Oh, we could show off some of the cookies that we have.
yes as you guys can see we have 173 out of 175 cookies which
um uh which is first of all insane but also we're missing
maybe the very two that we have to pull for the gotcha uh
perhaps all of them have like some of the exclusive outfits
on right now too yeah oh my god there was one some of them
have matching outfits too no way wait that's so cute like
look at this one it is time we returned to the purity oh my
god do i know so cute there was one cookie accurate cookie
down here that was wearing an outfit but i was like wait i'm
obsessed with this outfit i think you'll know it when you
see it my strength is yours yes i use that outfit for angel
cookie too it's that's the best outfit they're so cute look
at how cute angel but then they give this one.
Wait, so who's your favorite?
Oh, I see, I saw someone talking about onion cookie earlier.
Onion cookie is cute.
And voiced by Lily Petrie.
Oh, wait, really?
Yeah, so scared.
Oh, I hear it.
Oh, my God.
I hear it, right?
Yeah.
So cute.
Sonic the Hedgehog!
And then there was a Sonic event.
Yeah, there was a Sonic event.
So, like, me, Sida, and Vicky right now.
You could go to Green Hills.
Yo!
Hey!
Yeah!
Oh my god, they're so cute too.
There was a whole Sonic event and there were rings and you
could go to the Green Hills.
There's a BTS event.
A BTS event!
Oh my god, stop.
Dark Enchantris Cookie is so nice.
So cute.
So who's your favorite?
Wait, tell me when to stop.
Oh.
Also, her?
Milky Way was one of them.
Milky Way.
Which one?
They are very good cookies.
She might be...
She will be one of these epic ones.
Oh, my God.
I love this outfit.
It's so cute.
Such a good outfit.
It is.
It's very you.
Very cool.
Yeah.
This is an original default.
Epic outfit is so good.
She's a maid for one of the super epic cookies.
Right.
So, I think Milky Way is probably...
Well, she has one of these epic cookies.
I guess we could keep scrolling.
Keep scrolling.
I wonder what order these are in.
Yeah, keep scrolling.
Okay.
You'll recognize her even with the other outfit on.
Oh, there, on the far right.
Far right.
No keyway.
She's got the anniversary outfit on.
Look at you.
Let's see.
Oh, my gosh.
The default.
Oh, my God.
Wrong sleeves, right?
Yeah.
No, she's so cute.
She's my favorite.
It was so stinking cute.
Fourth anniversary outfit.
Weeeee!
Oh my goodness.
So we do have the other outfits.
And if you go to the far left, and you go down a little bit.
Not that one.
Next one.
That one's the one voiced by Horea Yui in the Japanese
version.
Cotton cookie.
Cotton cookie!
Her story made me cry.
She's got like a whole story with her and Uh, and the Jack
Frost cookie, like whatever Frost cookie or whatever.
They're cute together.
They're very cute.
I just can't get over like how intricate the outfits are for
like these cookies, you know?
Like they're just so...
The designs are amazing.
The designs are amazing and it's really stylistic.
And what's really funny is like there's a Yo Star store in
Akihabara, right?
And I go for Blue Archive, but then they have Cookie Run
cookies.
too what yeah oh i gotta go i know i know we'll go we'll go
buy some actual cookie run cookies like it's really funny
it's so i'm always just like this is so like i love this
outfit so much it's so stinking for him but yeah let's uh so
we'll go pull later for for these two these are our what is
this they're so funny let's see so cute and yes this account
let me just let me just phrase again because you see all
these amazing cookies this was provided to me by dev sisters
it is a temporary account so I don't get to keep it
unfortunately but we will still graciously we'll have great
luck and we'll be able to pull everything right well i
believe i believe yeah wait maybe we should gotcha then i
don't know well let me actually before then there was the
episode 13 the at the edge of light and darkness the newest
the newest episode um the story is really truly like well
written for this and the side stories as well oh i think for
this one You have to go to a story in the top left.
Yeah, I was going to say this is different from where top
left.
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah.
It's under Master, right?
Oh, wait.
Actually, go back.
Wait, yeah.
It was different.
Or go to World Map, maybe.
Because there's, like, the regular story.
Yeah.
At some point, they change chapters to the Beast East.
Right, right.
Oh, you know what?
This is on Crispia.
And then the other continent is Beast East.
So if we go to the bottom left to World Map, maybe it'll be
there.
Sorry, there we go.
There it is.
Yeah.
Beesies.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
Our team, they look so strong, too.
Right, right, right.
Are you ready to guide me into the ultimate battle?
I will do my best.
I'll do my best.
All right.
Look at our words stacked, though.
I think we'll...
I think we got those.
I think we can do it.
I think so.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
They look so beautiful.
Start.
Yeah, let's just start anyway.
Let's go!
Phoebe, General Phoebe.
They're running!
The cookies are running!
Oh, you could put it...
What you dreamed of giving to cookie kind?
It was freedom.
Spoiler alert to some people.
Spoiler alert!
Boom!
It means nothing to me anymore.
The voice acting, though.
The VA is so good, too.
Right?
No.
I'll just turn it on.
Yeah.
Quite little cookie.
Get back.
Charcoal cookie.
Silent salt cookies.
Blade cross this entire hall.
Wall to wall.
And left slash marks so deep, you can't see the bottom.
You can't see the bottom.
Oh my god.
Resonating with his rage.
Yeah.
Freedom!
Even restored, it will not mend your power and spirit cut in
half.
The soul jams are like super strong artifacts.
There's only the five for the ancient cookies like White
Lily Cookie.
I may have failed, but I was given one last chance to undo
my wrongs.
To make things right, I need to know about the power of the
witches that you used.
A cookie.
See, cookie run is serious.
Cookie run is serious.
Oh my goodness.
Really is.
It's no different from those of the vile beasts.
Oh my goodness.
We're totally, like, thrown into the middle of the story,
everyone, so don't feel bad if you don't know what's going
on.
But it's just kind of, like, a...
Yeah.
Giving you a little bit of a taste, though.
So without getting into too much spoilers, White Lily...
cookie like went, she wanted to discover why she was, or why
the cookies were born, why they were baked.
And then she looked into it too much and was, found out why
they were baked.
And it was shocking knowledge to her.
It was like forbidden knowledge for a reason.
And it sent her into dismay.
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
But I won't say anything else.
It is very, as extensional as, I will be born.
Actually, it's so intriguing.
Like, right?
Oh, my gosh.
Alright, I am going to skip ahead, though, so that we do
have time to fight.
Oh, my goodness.
Wait, I think we're, like, okay.
Oh, hold on, Otto.
Go on, Otto, real quick.
Otto!
Yeah.
And then, oh, oh, this is nice.
They set you up with, like, the meta treasures on the right
side.
I think we're, like, extremely okay.
Stuff that, like, maybe you can pull down.
Yeah.
This is like...
Easy.
That was GG easy.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
The dream team.
I wish I was that strong.
So yeah, the cookies do run.
They do run.
And so you can run through...
You can run through the whole newest episode.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
The story actually sounds so awesome though.
So...
There's a boss at the end of every level.
Every 30 levels.
a blast?
Ooh.
Spooky.
This is so long.
Wow.
Look at the little dogs.
Right.
Look how cute they are.
They're cute, huh?
Yeah.
There's like, um, some, oh, there was like a level that was
at, like, a wizard academy and there was some ghosty, ghosty
little things there.
I think you'd like it.
I would like it.
I would love that.
Yeah.
Is it like this starry wizard academy?
I wonder, oh my gosh, what if we get, dark enchantress
cookie and then we like put her on our team wait but she
would have to be i guess we could like level her up like to
max and then yeah i could level her up he has a completely
new rarity of cookie like more than epic and super epic and
stuff oh wait oh yeah there she is there she is there she is
there she is and it's she's part she's the first witch
cookie first witch cookie wait that's insane okay guys
phoebe grant us your luck I'll do my best That's me blowing
luck at you
There's like a way to know That you got like a good cookie
What was it?
So this one It's when she mixes, right?
You can tell from Yeah, when she mixes But also at the
beginning When the cookies pop up You can kind of tell How
good the pull is going to be Oh, so we're going to at least
get We're going to at least get like rare cookies in this
one yeah yeah nice but we're not gonna get our witch but we
didn't get epic or higher all right we'll just skip then
we'll skip everybody's max all right let's try again we got
this oh so much currency we got this we got this so that's
an okay-ish sign but nothing super yet oh there here here oh
Woo, woo, woo, woo, when you get an epic or...
Oh!
Okay.
That's more than an epic, though.
That's something else.
Wait.
Press it.
I'm pressing.
No!
What the?
Cookie in space.
What?
What could it be?
Because also that was a...
of cookie cutter that i haven't seen very much before so
something quite rare is gonna come out we did get the epic
but ginger brave soul so we're getting we're getting some
soul cores wait there this no way uh-huh oh black sapphire
cookie wow look at that cute wow I feel like we were so
close.
Nice.
Muscle cookie.
Oh, they're so cute.
I haven't seen Black Something cookie before.
Black Sapphire?
Black Sapphire, yeah.
But we did not get Dark Enchantress cookie.
So, again, again, again.
And there are even rarer cookies than Epic.
That we can get.
That's a good sign.
Streamer luck, everybody.
So I think at the beginning, it's like if you see a bunch of
rare friends pop up, then that means that there's going to
be...
We're going to get multiples of the rare cookies.
Good sign.
We got one.
Epic or higher.
Angel cookie!
So cute.
So the soul cores, they're to unlock the cookies or what
they're doing.
What kind of, like, when you get a Soul Core?
Either to unlock them if you don't have them yet, or to
upgrade them.
This is an epic, I think.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't think this is her, but...
I love these intros.
They're so fun.
Yeah.
Werewolf cookie?
I feel like I should- I wonder how some of these cookies
would taste.
A werewolf cookie!
Kind of hairy.
He looks like so Don't talk to me, me Angi Let's see Again,
again Again, again Again, again Come on, give me the hard
eyes Dang it You could skip this one probably I think so,
we'll skip Skip, skip, skip, skip That's alright.
Again!
Wait, many people showed up.
Oh!
Wait, we've only done a couple polls and like we're already
getting so many epics.
This is kind of awesome.
I know, right?
I like that the cookie smashes the table.
If you press tip in the top right, then it'll maybe stop
when you stop at an epic.
Oh, wait!
Oh, we already got it.
So this is the one that we just got.
Oh, is this gonna be...
This might be...
Oh, yes, it's the diver one.
Diver cookie!
Oh, cute.
Candy Diver.
Candy Diver cookie!
So cute!
Oh, my God.
I love that it looks like a little candy bowl, like his
head.
I know, right?
It's so cute.
Very cute.
Very, very cute.
The designs are so, like, creative.
Oh, okay.
and then on the bottom oh sorry okay i went too fast see
what we get i saw that i could claim it i did you're so
strong i am excited yeah you can claim it here i'll just
skip it this one yeah here so now yeah if you claim that on
the bottom left that just gives you more currency more free
currency to pull you'll get guaranteed stuff from like doing
more pulls but then after 200 250 pulls, you get, like, a
good...
You get pity.
You get the... Yeah, 250 is the pity.
So this is just one of the gotchas.
This is the witch, the enchantress.
Yeah, enchantress.
I don't think so, yeah.
I only saw...
Yeah.
Ginger Brain show up, so...
Alright.
Again!
I love Ginger Brain, but...
Again, again!
Wait, wait.
Three guys came out.
Oh, but it'll just be rare, I think.
Just a rare, I'll Oh.
Just rares.
Oh.
I'll skip her.
It's okay.
Skip her, skip her.
Still precious friends.
Oh, so cute.
They are really cute.
Come on, Dark Enchantress.
Come home.
Come home, come home, come home, come home, come home.
It's just rares.
Oh, it's rares.
Yeah.
Do games, or do, do poles flip usually?
Is that a chance for that?
Not at this point.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Again.
Gotcha, and this is so fun, though.
It's so, it's so, like, animated, which is really exciting.
Like, it makes you be like...
It is.
We got more stuff!
Yay!
Wow.
So much stuff.
Two friends.
Yeah, like this is the point where it can flip.
Yeah.
Oh, so it just did...
We got at least one.
At least one.
Bang!
I love it.
It goes to space.
I'm gonna...
Oh.
No, it wasn't this one.
Oh my gosh.
Cute!
Also cute.
There's so many cute cookies.
I don't want to skip, though, because...
Cute.
This is the one, right?
There you go.
This is the one.
There we go.
It's going to be an epic.
Oh, it's them!
My gosh.
Them.
That's Choco Cookie!
Choco!
I don't feel like you've ever seen one that's like two
cookies in one.
Yeah!
So stinking cute.
So baby.
Yeah, they come with a little intro screen.
It's so fun.
Nope.
Okay, that was like an NG poll.
Yeah.
It happens, it happens.
Oh.
Oh!
I was hovering over the skip.
Yeah!
Do you think it'll be...
It'll... she'll do the hard eyes?
Or do you think we'll get...
Something else?
That's the best I've ever seen is those eyes.
Yeah.
But if she's...
But who knows if they've added more.
Because it's different from an epic cookie.
It could be different.
Right.
Well, typically...
You'll be able to see the...
Oh my god, this one is cute too.
Oh my god, the panda!
The rock star!
Rock star cookie!
There's a whole rock festival event at some point.
And there was like a song that came out with it too.
Oh my gosh.
Oh wow, we just got 60 out of 60 for him.
Eh, he can level up.
Yeah!
Keep going.
We keep going.
More sparkly eyes.
We're getting so many epics though.
Right?
The point at which you can see what kind of a cookie you get
is like, uh, when...
In a little bit.
So...
When these start popping up, like when they come out of the
oven, you can like tell if like the dough looks a little
different.
Oh.
So we've seen the epic ones so far.
And, you know, the rare and stuff.
It'll be even fancier looking.
Fancy dough.
Look around cookies, cookie.
Okay.
Yeah, it's like at this point.
This looks like an epic as well.
Whoa!
Madeline cookie.
I believe.
Come on.
Dark Enchantress cookie.
At the end of each pull.
We also then also have to pull for Moldo cookie as well.
There's so many other cookies too.
How many other banners and stuff?
I know.
There's like so many events as well and everything.
Fruit juice cookie.
Yeah.
Oh, these are the outfits too.
The epic outfits.
I kind of want to do some outfit polls as well.
Yeah, this is the one and this is the video I showed in the
last stream, but we'll watch it again.
Master needs no script.
They brave the stage.
Brave the stage.
But me!
But she has the popular skin.
in a tragedy of his own making
I love her look so cute She's so cute Let's try it, I want
to pull Eternal Sugar Cookie Oh, so cute There are different
points at which you can see how good the gotcha is here too
Okay So this is like as though we got some rares basically
Okay, okay Cut We'll do it, we'll do the first one
Everything is so animated.
But kind of like...
Yeah.
Funky rainbows.
Cute!
For poison mushroom cookie.
Wait, I've got to do another one.
Wait, this is so cute too.
I want to see like a rare one.
Or epic one, I mean.
Right.
So this is also just normal.
Yeah, this is just normal as well.
We must, I want to see, I want to see.
Mm-hmm.
More, more, more.
I believe we have a little bit of currency left.
Yeah, we don't have too much, but...
It seems to be okay so far.
Yeah, it also seems pretty normal.
Oh my god, I was about to be like, what happened to you?
Oh, I love herb cookie though.
Herb cookie is...
He's one of my favorites.
Okay, come on.
Oh, I noticed the outfit outside was different.
Yes.
At that point, and then also at that point, and then at the
point where you see the kind of thread going around.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So this is just like normal.
Okay.
So we were getting pretty lucky getting rares before.
Wow, nice.
Right, right, right.
Yeah, because the dress in the window was different.
Let's see, there's my...
Oh!
They were fancy!
Oh, there!
There!
We got...
That's either...
But it can either be, like, an epic or, like, one of the
current... Yeah.
Uh, yes.
So, but hopefully we get one of the two featured outfits.
Oh?
Ah!
Fellflower Hall.
It's so pretty.
Oh, I really wanted Eternal Show.
Oh, no.
That's okay.
No more.
It's okay.
We got it.
They're so cute.
We have- All the outfits are super cute.
We have Dark Enchantress Cookie to grab.
We have Eye on the Prize.
I do have more of her currency at that.
Yeah, we have Eye on the Prize.
Come on.
We could take a break at some point.
to do the the mold cookie one this one yeah yeah yeah you
know what we'll do that we'll do that real quick whoa it's
rainbow oh i think it's just normal right i think so yeah
yeah that's okay come home somebody come home please
somebody come home I'm skipping.
We're skipping.
She's so cute.
Stick and cute.
But now you're getting so fast at knowing if it's a good
point.
Oh!
Yeah, that's a good sign.
That's a good sign.
Guaranteed at least in Epic.
Yeah.
I didn't see...
I think multiple will come home.
Whoa!
Yep!
Sorry.
I didn't see if he was a different thing other than Epic or
what.
Carrot cookie!
Three of them.
Holy moly.
Oh boy.
I'm sorry to... I feel like I'm taunting you, Phoebe, and
like we don't... neither of us get to keep this account,
but...
No.
Oh, we get to experience the joy of...
New cookie.
That's why the boys... Whoa!
What?
Oh!
We got him!
Command me!
This one's epic!
Wait!
We got him twice!
Which would be if this was an account that you could keep
very good?
Because then you get this person for me!
Yeah!
Wait, we still have a third one.
We have a third one.
What if it's three in a row?
Wouldn't that be crazy?
That'd be crazy.
That'd be so crazy.
I was secretly hoping.
Oh, it's mango, I think.
Maybe?
Grapefruit!
Cute!
Oh, they're cute.
Oh my gosh!
I got moldy dough cookie!
Oh my gosh.
bowl dough cookie ghetto but my enchantress come on please
we have just a few more just a few more ten full or 11 more
ten I think this one was a no good yeah yeah we'll zoom
through it we'll zoom oh claim all I think what do you do
with the extra cook it will upgrade them because they need
to be like just like in any other gotcha game they can get
stronger and stronger with the more copies you have of them.
So it's worth having other copies.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's typically how a lot of gotcha games were.
I'm skipping.
Rare.
Alright.
We have eight more tries.
Alright, come on.
Oh, come on.
It's the desire meter.
They know I want her.
It is the desire meter.
Ah!
Sweet!
She is?
She is extra, extra rare though.
Yeah, I just want to see her intro, so bomb.
I know, right?
I want to hear her voice.
No!
I shall become more terrifying than any witch.
Oh, that's spoilers!
That's spoilers!
She's so awesome.
Yeah, don't think too hard about that animation.
Don't think too hard about it.
I do not see it.
I do not see.
You are prepared to look into darkness.
Wow!
Oh, she's so cool.
So awesome.
Wait, it only showed Ginger Brave, though.
I didn't think that we would...
Wow, we did it!
I know, Rob.
Well, there was that second point at which it can flip.
That's true.
So I guess it flipped for you.
I was too eager.
Wow!
A good job!
Yay, let's go check her out.
real quick in our cookie area oh wait i guess they would be
uh how is it uh let's see oh it's by rarity so maybe i'll
wait at the tipi top oh my gosh your fate is sealed i love
like the the struggle all you want i i don't know the tears
your fate is sealed so yeah yeah yeah so so cool also it
came to my attention we did an episode from or we did a
chapter or like a one of the games from chapter episode 12
but there's episode 13.
oh it's 12 but 13 is new yeah 13 this one is all finished
here that was my bad i'm sorry i'm gonna skip all of the uh
story i'm so sorry go forth little one no spoilers no
spoilers there's millennial tree his banner just finished
The Forbidden Laboratoryum Island.
Whoa.
Because, uh, Dark Enchantress Cookie was trying to create
the ultimate cookie for a while, artificially.
So, I love these, like, cans and stuff.
So funny.
But, yeah, so.
All right.
Well, we showed you how the game works, but now you can get
to episode 13 and play it for yourself.
No spoilers.
We didn't spoil anything for you.
No, if you're to finish episode 13, there is a...
There's that new castle skin that unlocked if they...
Yeah, yeah!
You can go peek at it.
Let's peek it.
Let's peep it.
It is in...
Dark Enchantress Cookie.
A mold dough cookie.
Yeah, so you can even change how your castle looks and
everything.
It is cute!
See?
customization so once you beat oh 1330 you can get the dark
enchantress cookie citadel and look at all these other ones
that you can get and customize your kingdom to how you like
it they are so cute they're so cute they're like uh they've
added a lot of customization because before you could only
really like decorate the the kingdom itself and put
different buildings Now you have the skins for the castle
and the fountain and the train.
And then also, they've added a thing where you can make your
OC cookie as well.
And walk around in an MMO environment with your custom
cookie.
It's really cute.
It's really, really, really cute.
Yeah.
Well, thank you guys.
Just keep adding.
Thank you so much for joining us for the little sneak peek
of the 5th anniversary.
for cookie run kingdom thank you dev sisters for sponsoring
and for allowing me to play on this temporary account even
though we got to do it i would love to have this account for
myself i think i think everybody can go up to level 100 now
that's crazy it was not that high before so thank you
everybody if you are so interested now in cookie run kingdom
which phoebe totally sold us like thank you so much phoebe
my cookie You're an expert here.
Please use the link in the pinned comment or down below.
And yeah, thank you guys so, so much.
Don't forget all these codes up here.
Free stuff.
Yes.
I say this as a fellow player.
Don't forget your free stuff.
Yeah, take all that.
They're throwing free stuff at you.
So please take the free stuff so that you can catch up if
you're a new player or, you know, enhance your cookies even
more if you are a veteran.
so yeah yeah let's celebrate five years of cookie run
kingdom together thank you so much cookie run for sponsoring
thank you thank you thank you dev sisters and thank you
mento for letting me be on here and yap with you of course i
love you feeding i love you so much and i'll uh i'll let you
know if that christopher robin challenge is on or not oh
yeah it's yeah let me know I'll get ready for it too Heck
yeah We'll be raiding into Phoebe's stream after this So you
can keep watching Phoebe Be So cute and get rage At Winnie
the Pooh game Thank you everybody Thank you Bye bye And I
booze Bye bye Love you Phoebe and I booze And Beehive
everybody Thank you Bye bye Bye-bye.